ينضم لينا من امستردام يبدي هوب شبر
الامينو العام السابق لخلفي الشمال
الاطلسي
سيدر وزير الدفاع الالماني قال بان بلاده
لا تعارض نقل دبابات للبرد اثنان الى
اوكرانيا من جانب واحد
ولكنه قال في الوقت نفسه
مستعده للتحرك بسرعه اذا تم التوصل الى
توافق بين الحلفاء اين يختلف الحلفاء هنا
جامني
المانيا تحتاج الى المزيد من الوقت
السياسيا لكن اعتقد ان الرئيس بوتان
وروسيا بامكانها ان تتاكد ان دبابات لبرد
ستصل الى ما اخذنا بالنظر الاعتبار ان
الرئيس بوتين تهيا لي ربما لهجوم الربيع
خلال فصل الاشهر القادمه انها متاكد تماما
ان هذه الدبابات الدبابات لا برده ستصل
الى اوكرانيا قد يكون الوقت متاخرا ربما
ليس هنالك توافقات حتى الان كما ذكرت في
رمش ثاني يوم امس لكنها هذه توافقه ستحصل
لانه هنالك عدد من الكثير من الدول لديها
دبابات وهي قادره على ارساله تلك الدبابات
الى اوكرانيا
درس درس
في المانيا لكن عندما يريد بلد ثالث ان
ينقل هذه الدبابات الى دوله اخرى فان
المانيا عليها ان تعطي الضوء الاخضر
بالتالي هذا نوع من العائق في الاجراءات
لكن اذا ما اخذنا بنظر الاعتبار ان هنالك
الخضر وحزبه الليبرالي في المانيا وهم
يفضلون ايضا هم جزء من التحالف الحكومه
وهم يفضلون ارسال هذه
الدبابات ايضا
المستشارك همم من حزب الخضر تحدث بشكل
واضح لدعم عن دعمه في نهايه المطاف فاعتقد
ان الحزب الاشتراك الديمقراطي والمستشار
شرطي هو الذي اخذ القرار الاخير هو يحتاج
الى بعض الوقت فقط لكن كما قلت اعتقد ان
هناك ستكون هنالك موافقه عاجلا ام عاجلا
كنت قبل قليل
ان يتوقع ربما تحول في المعارك هل هذا ما
يفسر ربما نشر موسكو منظومه صواريخ اس 300
واجراء منورات دفاعيه تحاكي هجوم همم فوق
موسكو
رئيس بوتن يتهيا لكل شيء هو يشنه حربا
عدائيه ان يقوم باختصار النساء
البنايات السكنيه في انحاء مختلفه في
اوكرانيا
والكثير من المصادر الان تؤكد انه ربما
يتجه نحو شاني هجوم ربيعي او هجمه الربيع
بعد انتهاء فصل الشتاء واعتقد ان هذا ما
نتوقعاه وكان سبب تجمع الدول الغربيه في
رمشتان لكي تعطي اوكرانيا الامكانيات لكي
تدافع عن نفسها ضد هذه الحرب العدائي قوه
بامكانيه هذا الحرب متى ماشي يشاء عن طريق
مغادره اوكرانيا وصاحبي جنوده جنوده الروس
الى خلف الحدود هو لا يريد القيام بذلك
ولا يقوم بذلك اعتقد انه لا لد الغرب
والاوكرانيا لديها كل الحق وايضا اعضاء
نيته في ان تساعده اوكرانيا في الدفاع عن
نفسها مساعده اوكرانيا في الدفاع عن نفسها
ولكن هل تعتقد بان استمرار هذه الحرب
واستمرار تزويد اوكرانيا همم سوف ينهي هذه
الحرب اذا تم استمر تزويدها بالسلاح امن
همم تزويدها كمان يصب البنزين على النار
كما قال همم احد المسؤولين الاوروبيين هذا
اليوم
في الفرن النيش
ما اتت دوله اجنبيه الى بلدك واحتلته
وقالت ان هذا بلدي ستقوم بقتل المدنيين
واستهداف كل شخص هذه الدوله لديها الحق
للدفاع عن نفسها ساذكروا فقره 51 من ميثاق
الامم المتحده العنف والعنف العسكري هو
يتم تبريره في حاله الدفاع عن النفس
بالتالي ليس هنالك اي حديث عن مسالتي صب
الزيت على النار هذا حق شرعيه حق الدفاع
عن نفسه دعار لروسيا يتركونا اوكرانيا
وستنتهي الحرب فورا انا لي سوء الحظ لا
يتوقع حدوث ذلك اعتقد اننا همم
تواجهنا حرب مطوله واكرانيا تواجهها هذه
الحرب المتطاوله لكن عندما اراد الرئيس
بوتن هذا السيناري سيحصل عليه ونحن لن نسم
حال روسيا بان تنتصر في هذه الحرب نريد
اوكرانيا ان تنتصر في هذه الحرب وعندما
تنتصر اوكرانيا
قد نجد
همم ننظر الى اذا ما كان هنالك ربما اذا
ما يجب على الحرب ان تنتهي وهنالك شخص
واحد الرئيس بامكانه ان يوقف هذه الحرب
فورا
امستردام شكرا جزيلا